in washington where another fable is uh
playing out that is the state of the
union address annual event big big day
in washington president biden is given
his first tonight and as he does so he
faces a mountain of domestic and global
issues including covid inflation and of
course that war in ukraine a cbs news
poll out this morning shows that his
approval rating slid from 61 percent to
44 percent during his first year in
office let's go to ed o'keefe at the
white house for us ed good morning the
numbers are showing that americans do
care about foreign policy but they are
split along party lines on whether they
approve of the president's handling of
the situation in ukraine so is he ready
to tackle that issue tonight
absolutely tony good morning aides say
now it's going to be the big focus of a
speech that wasn't what they expected to
have to focus on just a few weeks ago
but they understand that the unfolding
situation now merits that the president
expected to talk about defending
democracy not just in ukraine but but
around the world and he's going to get
into exactly how the us is helping
ukraine and lay out those historic
economic sanctions against russia for
their deadly invasion as global stocks
took a dive in oil prices surged when
the conflict began we expect him to
discuss how he plans to limit the impact
on the rest of the world and here at
home that new cbs news poll we mentioned
shows 63 percent of americans say the
economy is doing badly more than 50
percent say they're concerned about
their ability to pay for things like gas
and groceries the president is expected
to call on congress to help americans
financially by expanding health care
offering new child tax credits and
raising the federal minimum wage to 15
dollars an hour and lastly is coveted
requirements are changing all across the
country as cases go down there's an
expectation the president will talk a
bit about how we move into a
post-pandemic phase we should also point
out the republican response will be
given tonight by iowa's governor kim
reynolds in des moines and as is
tradition the president will hit the
road tomorrow he's going to wisconsin
with the first lady to talk about his
domestic agenda tony
that response speech is always
challenging for either party we're
looking forward to that as well ed thank
you very much